♪ Illégal
♪ Tu me fais faire des bêtises
♪ Dans les rues de Montréal
- Marjo, vous êtes la reine du
rock québécois.
- bien oui!
- Vousererer chanter sur les
Plaines d'Abraham pour le
spectacle de la Fête nationale.
Comment expliquez-vous qu'encore
aujourd'hui, vous avez le rock
dans la peau?
MARJO, auteure-compositeure-
interprète
- La musique... la musique est
dans moi. J'en manquerais si
j'arrêtais. Je le jure.
Puis eususus, ma mère est native
de Québec. Ça fait que moi,
quand je rentre dans Québec,
je suis chez nous.
J'ai l'impression d'être la
suite de maman, ce que je suisd,
Québec, c'est... c'est dans mon
coeur. C'est la fierté d'être
Québécoise.
♪ Allons danser
Ça fait que quand ils
m'appellent puis ils disent:
"Marjo, veux-tu être avec nous
autres sur le show?" Oui!
- J'ai retrouvnsnsns nos
archives une entrevue de 1981 et
vous dites la phrase suivante :
Tu penses-tu que je vais chanter
du rock'n'roll jusqu'à l'âge de
50 ans?
- Bien oui!
- On est encore ici. Alors,
qu'est ce qui s'est passé?
Vous avez changé d'idée?
- Puis je vais en avoir 69!
Incroyable, mais vrai.
Tu penses-tu que je vais
chanter du rock'n'roll jusqu'à
l'âge de 50 ans?
50 ans!
Non, non, non!
Je vais être ailleurs.
Quand je suis rentrée dans
Corbo, je ne visualisais pas
comme : Bon, bien moi, je vais
faire de la musique jusqu'à 100
ans. Non, non, c'était un trip.
♪ ♪ ♪
Je visais pas. Je vis le moment
présent. Finalement, c'est ça.
Marjo, elle vit le moment
présent.
- "Chats sauvage"s, Marjo!
- L'été 1987 m'a vraiment
marqué, parce que "Cha
sauvage", ça jouait partout.
J'ai fait ma recherche dans les
palmarès, c'était la chanson de
l'été 1987, il y a 35 ans.
- L'album, je l'avais intitulé
"Celle qui va", parce que
d'après moi, c'était la chanson,
parce que le texte était
vraiment beau. Et puis non,
c'était "Chats sauvages", puis
moi "Chats sauvages", c'est un
texte de bébé lala. J'étais une
fille qui comence. Je commençais
à écrire, je commençais à dire
qui j'étais un petit peu mieux
que Corbeau. J'abordais un peu
plus des beaux thèmes, voilà.
Mais c'est rentré d'aplomb,
je l'attendais pas!
- Non, vraiment pas?
- Non, pantoute! Zéro!
♪ Cette chanson
♪ Elle est pour nous
Donner de la joie du bonheur de
l'emprunt, et la bague, ça s'en
va, c'est trop.
C'est beaucoup trop.
(applaudissements)
- L'été 1947 m'a vraiment
marqué, paququque je chômage
était partout.
C'était la chanson de l'été.
- L'aldedede l'intitulé par ce
que c'était la chanson.
Non, chat sauvage, je sais que
t t t sur la liberté, mais ce
étététait pas, c'était une fille
qui commençait à écrire, je
commençais à dire qui j'étais,
un petit peu mieux, j'abordais
un peu plus les bons termes,
voilà, c'est rentré d'aplomb, je
ne l'attendais pas.
- Vous vous faites tout un
cadeau pour septembre prochain.
Vous allez être coach à
"La Voix". Vous n'avez pas sorti
d'album avec des chansons
originales depuis plus de
15 ans. Qu'est ce qui se passe?
Est-ce que vous avez besoin d'un
compositeur, d'un paro???
- Ça, j'aimerais bien ça,
ais je crois que ça va arriver
après "La Voix". Je pense qu'il
y a quelque chose qui va se
passer après "La Voix".
Mais le quququoi du 15 ans,
c'est que depuis 2014, j'ai
décidé que je prenais ma vie de
musicienne et d'auteure en main.
Donc je fais tout et la
logistique et trouver les bons
musiciens. Des fois, j'en
essaie. Je fais non, non, c'est
pas ça. Je m'occupe de tout,
tout, tout, tout, tout.
Donc ça, ça prend un temps
malade, je ne fais que ça.
Les gens qui veulent avoir Marjo
ititit en entrevue, en radio,
bla bla bla, passent par Marjo
sur mon courriel et je réponds
à tout le monde.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À l'âge de 28 ans,
vous avez dit en entrevue :
Il est temps que je m'assagisse.
- C'était Corbeau.
- Oui. Est-ce que vous vous êtes
assagie Marjo, avec le temps.
- Oui.
- Ah oui?
- Oui, oui. Maintenant,
cultive mon énergie, parce que
j'en ai besoin. Bien oui, bien
oui, bien oui. Avant, mon
énergie, je la pitchais partout.
Pius j'aimais ça, j'étais bien
puis je ne me rendais pas comptr
et à mesure. Et maintenant,
tu vois comme cette semaine,
j'avais quatre événements.
Donc je me suis dit : OK, le
premier, c'est beau.
Le deuxième, c'est beau. Ouo!
Ici, la répétition a été...
Ils nous demandaient de la faire
à fond. Donc il fallait chanter
pour vrÇa, c'était une
grosse journée, hier, alors
à 7 h, je dormais.
- Oh! Marjo, à 7h, vous dormiez!
- Oui, monsieur!
- Je crois pas ça.
- Bien oui, pour revenir en
forme aujourd'hui.
(rires)
esesest quatre jours en ligne qe
j'ai faits, là, c'est beaucoup!
- Marjo, vous m'avez fait un
beau cadeau.
- Un immense plaisir. Je t'aime.
♪ Les jours ressemblaient
♪ À